il n'y a pas que toronto qui a de grands
espoirs pour des projets
d'infrastructures en effet céline et
montréal d'ailleurs est en première
ligne pas juste pour boucher les nids de
poule mais bien pour des grands projets
d'infrastructures par exemple celui qui
vient à l'esprit c'est le prolongement
de la fameuse ligne bleue à montréal
donc cinq stations supplémentaires entre
saint michel et anjou c'est quand même 3
milliards de dollars on espère en tout
cas le mercredi et espère que le fédéral
va y mettre du sien également aux six
autres projets on parle d slr les fameux
train léger sur le pont champlain mais
également entre l'aéroport pierre-elliot
trudeau et le centre ville 5 milliards
de dollars c'est quand même des grandes
enveloppes et enfin autre projet cher à
monsieur coderre c'est l'usiné de
filtration aux toitures qui a besoin
vraiment de d'être remise au goût du
jour et l'on parle d'au moins 300
millions de dollars
mais aussi l'alberta qui connaît un
important ralentissement économique on
le sait et qui attend aussi un peu des
deux du fédéral oui pour faire repartir
la machine calgary par exemple est
intéressé à bonifier son offre de
services de transport en commun
on a quand même 5 milliards de dollars
là qu'on essaye d'avoir du fédéral le
fédéral se seraient commis pour à peu
près un tiers
c'est quand même un tronçon de 40 km qui
va du nord au sud à calgary
également on parle de logement abordable
la basse a fait défaut on a besoin de
logements abordables
un peu plus au nord et demi tonne cette
fois-ci là encore une fois on parle de
transport en commun on a besoin de
presque 2 milliards de dollars pour
augmenter le service de transport en
commun et aussi on a besoin d'un
milliard de dollars pour refaire le
réseau autoroutier qui est en très
mauvais état edmonton et hameaux
intervenant sur vancouver la riche qui
est un peu victime de son succès la
ville où il fait bon vivre
si vous êtes millionnaire évidemment à
vancouver par exemple il va falloir
bonifier aussi l'offre par exemple le
corps gordes corridor broadway c'est un
corridor qui très achalandé on a passé
de service passés de bus pas assez de
skytrain on voudrait également un très
léger entre serait et vancouver ça c'est
2 milliards de dollars
le sivos transport entre vancouver et
north vancouver
et puis évidemment dans la ville où
l'immobilier est un cauchemar permanent
on a besoin de logements abordables
on attend beaucoup de monsieur trudeau
et du budget de monsieur morneau demain
alors on saura ça nous demain après-midi
merci beaucoup frais avec l'anru